he is the host of the opposition with
Jordan Klepper every single night on
Comedy Central at 11:30 p.m. Eastern
Time after The Daily Show which is how
we first fell in love with him
nationally good to see you Jordan
Klepper what's going on man not much
good to be out in in balmy LA yeah so
you are shooting your show in New York
City we just saw a lot of walking and
talking but it did on the streets yes
New York yes that's right outside our
studio our studios in the lovely
Pennsylvania hotel which is a great
place to to make TV and to get bedbugs
and we're right across from Madison
Square Garden so we just head out into
the cast and Philip stay so the bedbugs
have gone across the street and is that
what's wrong with the Knicks is that
what it you know it could be it might be
let me tell you if it can destroy your
life it can destroy your NBA team like
bedbugs they are a killer and but the
walking and talking that I just saw
that's very impressive that's like you
could be you could do some sports
broadcast with the walk and talk like
that and you should see me with the walk
attack I could I can chew gum you didn't
see it there but I could do that as well
I'm a multi - I mean you were pointing
and leaving frame and finding your
camera no to be easy to do yeah now that
wasn't all one take you know sometimes
I'm I don't remember to leave frame
sometimes I'm pointing in the wrong
direction but eventually we get a
product that makes it look like I'm
somebody who should be on television
yeah and the piece for our ad audience
that we just saw you were kind of
spoofing the president's comments when
the North Korean hostages came home
saying that they broke a ratings record
at 3:00 in the morning they did and you
named a whole bunch of TV shows that
whose ratings they broke that 3:00 in
the morning yes that you named a couple
of what great commercials in the mean I
think the president definitely has his
priorities straight there he knows where
to focus and I think he did defeat
Coneheads the movie that very morning is
it wrong for me to when I saw about
scene that that I thought of some like
Shannon Tweed film in the morning I
think that's actually that's you know
that's a really that's a good Rorschach
test of like close your eyes they go
what
what do you imagine in three am now what
do you see to me it was Coneheads or a
my pillow commercial Hey look we we we
talked my pillow here all the time so
we're breaking records I love that
Jordan Klepper here on the Rich Eisen
show now you sir are from the great
state of Michigan the great state of
Michigan yes Kalamazoo born and bred
okay
and that's home to Western Michigan
University and Kalamazoo College where I
went to college okay
is there a football program there is I
think that's probably the nicest way to
put it there is a football team
associated with Kalamazoo College it's a
small college it's like 1,500 people
I think the football team has at least
20 people on it and so so they play both
they play both offense indeed they play
whatever you want yes they also teach
some classes like you take where you can
get it right
that's the Hornets but I'm a Michigan
proud so did you have any routing
allegiances football wise in the state
outside of LA Zoo i 100% did my fan I
grew up big Wolverine fans I was gonna
be named Bo if they won the Rose Bowl
that year luckily they did not well
that's most years unfortunately badly
hold on a second so what was hanging in
the balance here who was who was 79 it
was USC I believe it might have been
phantom touchdown active touchdown named
you do you are you familiar with that
phantom touchdown crisp I am NOT USC won
the game 1710 okay so it was at the
Charles White year is that what that was
Charles White was a running back for yes
Charles Lee okay if there was instant
replay they would have clearly shown
that the ball was loose he broke the
plane of the goal with no football in
his hand at Michigan then recovered yeah
it's one of the many injustice had been
perpetrated on Michigan football the
beautiful city Pasadena you're telling
me you know but if it gave me my name
I'm going to take it I will be the dog
the dog got named Bo we have a dog named
Bo my dad grew up loves Bo Schembechler
I did as well we got to we get to meet
him we would I would save up my money
they would have the Michigan football
bust every year where they'd hold it in
the Renaissance Center in Detroit and
after the season you could go and have
dinner
give out awards and fans could save up
like $50 and go meet the players and
that was like my big thing I would save
up my money all year and get to go to
the Renaissance Center and meet beau or
at least take a picture with him from
like 10 feet away so I mean my dad wore
my dad got us bowties so their bow ties
with little bows on it so just to make
me feel older but um you were so you
were born in 1979 so you were so you
were seven years old when I strolled on
to the campus efficient in him was
rooting for Jim Harper
well how about was my he was my first
favorite player that was it right yeah
that was I mean that's why when he came
back I couldn't be more excited that was
I had the big number for Jersey when you
I think I first went to a game at age
six but Harbaugh was the quarterback and
yeah it's night age six degree 1985 when
they lost to chuck long and Iowa yes yes
who then became a Detroit lion which I
remember my dad at the time I didn't
know all these different allegiances but
it was he had a hard time reading for
Chuck long I mean the Lions are always
hard to root for him but just to raise
the ball rooting for the Lions now you
got Chuck long and he's beating Michigan
in the past that's why we are Lions fan
section my brother works for the Lions
so we support the Lions love the Lions
but he does your brother do for the
Detroit he works in marketing for the
lion so he went to U of M he was the one
Klepper Klepper family member who
actually went to U of M he he worked
with the team and then after graduating
went to the Lions to like basically be
lazy the A's on between the players and
then also and now he's in the marketing
department over there how's the
marketing going yeah you know they're
still trying to restore that roar man
restoration project yeah that gets 40th
season I'd like restore the roar I think
that's that's a it's a good hook right
it's the colors that's the heart your
marketing but your marketing it's an
uphill battle with that silver and that
light blue excuse me I don't mean a pick
nits Jordan but it's Honolulu blue it's
called Honolulu
just because when you when you go into
the old silver dome you always thought
of a waffle if there's one thing when
you're in Pontiac Michigan it definitely
feels like you're in here in the Hawaii
of the Midwest I went when I was in
school there I'm with Jordan Klepper
Comedy Central the opposition with
Jordan Klepper when I was in school
there 1988 I went to a game in the
silver dome and it was the pre Wayne
Fonts Lions and the Joe Walton Joe must
go Walton New York Jets and I'm a New
York jet fan and went there got into the
building and they said I swear to you
pick any seat you want oh so I sat fifth
row 50-yard line with about 500 other
people I'm not kidding you this is not
an exaggeration Wow
but I got to say you know I even think
Barry Sanders was there yet
it was just that's that's why you guys
said they got a few more fans when Barry
came on board but when I was there it
was the Sparky Anderson Tigers he still
winning and it was the Jacques Demers
Red Wings right that were with idea is
that the Yzerman era I'm absolutely this
TV wire yeah and then even worse for
Knicks fan the bad boys Chuck Daly Isiah
Thomas Oh Bill Laimbeer kicking ass Rick
Mahorn arrow Pistons that was that was
the most fun I grew up I I have I mean I
remember getting those bad boys when
they went back-to-back loved lamb beer
Mahorn
liked lamb black beer I love my dad what
my dad always he loved Vinny the
microwave dad said they'd be like why do
they call him the microwave because he
heats up so fast because I loved it I
loved vide it was great - yeah Joe
Dumars and then team it was tough for me
as a New Yorker to swallow you know with
Ewing trying to beat them and couldn't
be damned and then when finally finally
somebody beat the Pistons it was Michael
freakin Jordan and nobody could beat him
but they're the good thing about being
very young at that time is when Michael
Jordan came around you know I was a
Pistons fan but Michael Jordan was so
fun and I was so young I had no problem
becoming a Chicago Bulls fan just just
like that so it's amazing because when I
I mentioned the Knicks fans that I
the the the I guess the villains if you
will that I can't couldn't stand as a
Knick fan I just removed Jordan from the
equation he's just he's not you he's
just on a different level he's a
different human being on the planet did
you enjoy watching him then was that I
mean I yeah but then I just I I was sick
and tired of him beating our brains in a
little Starks games those were so fun so
tell me about the opposition with Jordan
Klepper you're doing your own gig after
being on The Daily Show for many years
you it's funny you are doing some funny
works oh it's a it's a funny time to
live in and uh it's it's a blast yeah I
had a great job over the Daily Show
playing this buffoonish character and we
kind of heightened it to create this
opposition show where I play this
character who's he's fringy he's
far-right he's in the world of like the
Alex Jones and the sean hannity is like
creating his own reality anti mainstream
and so we sort of just take the chaos of
the day which there tends to be a lot of
it and we just we play around in that
muck and your characters not a fan of
the town in which we're currently
sitting he is not at all of Los Angeles
he is he is it's the Hollywood elites
the Hollywood elites
he's anti big Hollywood although if you
invited him to be a part of big
Hollywood he would drop all of that he
would be just wants to be invited wants
to be invited wants to go to that Vanity
Fair party okay he's gonna be czz
protests it he's against it he'll tweet
up me angrily about it if you give him
one little invitation he would drop it
all in a heartbeat is it true then after
your first segment on The Daily Show
that you sat in the live audience is
that a story that it's true yeah I what
was that all about I mean it happens I
was a huge Daily Show fan forever and I
was doing comedy forever and to get the
break to be on the show like that was a
dream come true it happened really
quickly my first day of work I show up
with the suit from my wedding a few
months earlier
they put me on the show and you know it
kind of an amazing moment to get to be
on the show with Jon Stewart do that
piece and then that thing ended I was
like I've never seen The Daily Show live
can I can I go watch and they were like
well I don't know where you want to sit
is like just break out a chair anywhere
I want to see what this thing looks like
he's nobody like Jon Stewart yeah there
really isn't
I miss him being on TV and again at just
kind of bringing this full circle joking
about your walk
in talking ability on the street nobody
could read a prompter like him and I
read a prompter for for a living and the
way I'm assuming a lot of that stuff was
on a teleprompter for him to be
discussing yeah I mean yes but he's able
to jump I mean that's that one thing you
know there's to read it and then ad lib
you're right that is a very specific sky
remember watching and watching along
with him doing that like where he
chooses to deviate how he plays right
it's very inside baseball but but it is
something like he's able to still add
add newness freshness to it read an
audience to see how they want to play
he'll rewrite jokes in the the prompter
like you'll see him jump ahead because
the audience was onboard with the
premise more than they are the punchline
like he's here's a probably did it for
16 years
it's unbelievable like in terms of you
know being a fan of his
there was the forget what it was xx
thousand SportsCenter when I was on
SportsCenter and I drew they they split
us up as the SportsCenter anchors to go
appear on different late-night shows and
I did to go on the daily show and I went
on and this was before he started
cursing regularly he started off by the
way he visited in the back when I picked
up on any any guest that comes here on
the show I will always want to go visit
in the back of course he stopped by he
couldn't have been greater and nicer and
then he starts off the interview by
saying 20,000 sports centers man huh
that's gonna be a whole bunch of Amit's
and BS he said the word and it was like
this Dwight Gooden twelve mid 12
midnight six o'clock curveball that
Spana I was totally thrown off I try to
be funny it was a disaster that lives on
the internet forever and I would I wish
I could have had him all again he's just
the best there's nobody like oh I love
it in that first moment like I blew it
I was right here and when you walk in
around town two people think you're
you're that right-wing guy that you play
on to you sometimes for sure I think
what I go to a trump rally as we talk
about those things I think people
embrace that POV and that px it's there
and so and then some people have seen
the show and some people are fans on the
right some people are angry and will
chase me down some fans do the exact
same thing as well so it's a
a confusing time was about to say that's
how that there's people who feel
polarized here's a way I've noticed it's
a polarized country well you're very
keen observer thank you I noticed some
things at Jordan Klepper on Twitter
check out the opposition with Jordan
Klepper every single week not 11:30 p.m.
Eastern Time on Comedy Central please
let me know when you're back in this
scourge of law sending out what the
elites of el segundo you bet that's
Jordan Klepper here on the Rich Eisen
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience